Das ist schon eine wenig verrückte idee aber am ende vielleicht nicht so blöd china will einen künstlichen zweiter mond ins all schicken
der himmelskörper sollen nachts licht zur erde schicken damit eine stadt
erleuchtet werden kann der effekt es kann eine menge energie gespart werden weil die
straßenbeleuchtung ausgeschaltet werden kann
schöne idee aber wie will man einen ganzen mond ins all schicken und was passierte alles noch in china klicks um
science-fiction bei uns gibt es jeden tag ein video mit spannenden facts news abonniert den kanal nur dann verpasst ihr nichts
okay let's go herzlich willkommen
Eine absolut geniale idee und sie wird schon länger überlegt aber in china macht man seit einigen jahren nägel mit köpfen ok erstmal zu beginn
einen ganzen mond schießen die chinesen natürlich nicht ins all woher und womit usw technisch nicht machbar
aber es geht kleiner aber genauso effektiv
zumindest für eine stadt
2020 soll ein satellit auf eine geostationäre bahn geschickt werden so wird zumindest vermutet der zumindest eine ganze stadt
beleuchten kann setzt das ist erst mal eine herausforderung
schenk du heißt die stadt die als erstes ihre straßenbeleuchtung
ausschalten können soll wohlgemerkt können soll es ist ein experiment niemand weiß ob es wirklich so hundertprozentig
funktioniert wie geplant bei den russen sind solche experimente in den 90er jahren schief gegangen aber
wenn es funktioniert könnte es die energiewende weltweit
revolutionieren und wie es funktioniert darüber hüllt sich china in schweigen eins ist sicher der satellit soll sonnenlicht auf die erde
reflektieren das geht nur auf einer geostationären bahn denn nur von dort kann
zuverlässig ein punkt auf der erde anvisiert werden nächte
sind dort viel kürzer weil der erdschatten so kleines maximaldauer die nacht war die nach jahreszeit
70 minuten und auf dem geostationären
orbit gibt es nur zwei stabile punkte an denen die satelliten bahn nicht ständig korrigiert werden müssten für china wäre das
75 grad ost optimal von dort aus wäre der satellit wegen der großen höhe sogar in der lage sie städte
auszusuchen wie der satellit allerdings genau konstruiertes dazu hüllt sich das entwicklungsteam in schweigen
nur so viel ließ man durchsickern der satellit soll acht mal so hell wie der mond sein das würde zur straßenbeleuchtung
ausreichend das gebiet das beleuchtet werden könnte würde einen durchmesser von 10 bis 80 kilometern haben
ein gigantisches
projekt es gibt aber auch kritik wie er reagiert die tierwelt wenn so große bereich beleuchtet werden und der plan wird wieder mal ein
schlaglicht auf die ambitionierte wissenschaftsszene in china inzwischen pumpt die regierung
dort milliarden in die raumfahrt dieses jahr könnten dort zum ersten mal mehr raketen starten als in den usa
2020 beginnen die chinesen mit dem bau einer raumstation
iss dann verschrottet werden muss dann gehört die einzige raumstation im orbit china
schon etwas bedenklich dass eine diktatur
die regie im weltraum übernimmt und auch bei den mond satelliten will man dranbleiben klappt das experiment sollen
2022 schon drei weitere künstliche monde in den erdorbit
staaten war da wird nicht groß gefackelt sondern einfach mal gemacht
wenn ihr dazu und zu allen weiteren themen kein video verpassen wollt dann endet meine nummer bei whatsapp dafür hier draufklicken
dann bekommt ihr den link zum aktuellen video
täglich persönlich noch vor allen andern von mir und zur begrüßung gibt es ein kleines geschenk ich freue mich auf euch hier geht es weiter
drunter dafür auch draufklicken china plant mascolo nie bis dann
bleibt dran